Dieser Roboter soll echt alles können: Schwimmen,
Fliegen, Rollen und sogar Tauchen.
Das Geheimnis des “Transformer-Roboters”:
Er kann seine Form und somit auch seine Fähigkeiten
verändern.
Die NASA möchte mit diesem Prototypen namens
“Shapeshifter” den Geheimnissen unerforschter
Himmelskörper auf die Schliche kommen, wie
zum Beispiel dem mysteriösen Saturnmonds
“Titan”.
Und der Roboter hat dafür wirklich extreme
Fähigkeiten.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Derzeit tüfteln NASA-Forschungsteams an einem
Prototypen mit dem Namen “Shapeshifter”
- übersetzt also so viel wie “Formwandler”.
Und der macht seinem Namen wirklich alle Ehre.
Tatsächlich erinnert er ein wenig an die
formwandelnden Roboter, die man bislang nur
aus Science-Fiction-Storys kennt.
Der Plan der NASA hat es aber in sich.
Denn der “Shapeshifter” soll seine Form
und somit auch seine Funktionen verändern
können.
Somit kann er sich an seine jeweilige Forschungsumgebung
anpassen und diese bestmöglich erkunden.
Je nachdem, in welchem Terrain sich der Transformer-Roboter
also bewegt, kann er Tauchen, Schwimmen, Fliegen
oder Rollen.
Super wichtige Voraussetzungen, um beispielsweise
den Titan zu erkunden.
Das ist der größte Saturnmond, der in einigen
Aspekten der Erde ziemlich ähnlich ist.
Die Sonde “Cassini” ist bereits an ihm
vorbeigeflogen und konnte seine Oberfläche
kartieren.
Auf ihm befinden sich Seen, Höhlen, Vulkane,
Inseln und Canyons.
Dennoch gibt es viele ungeklärte Fragen über
diesen Saturnmond.
Beispielsweise in Bezug auf den exotischen
Kreislauf von Kohlenwasserstoffen wie Ethan
und Methan, die hier mal als Eis oder Gas
oder aber als Flüssigkeit zirkulieren.
Und nicht nur das: Die Vulkane auf diesem
Mond spucken keine Lava, sondern Ammoniak.
Auch die titanischen Gewässer sind für die
Fachwelt noch ein großes Rätsel.
Dazu der NASA Forscher Ali Agha: “Wir haben
nur sehr begrenzte Informationen über die
Zusammensetzung der Oberfläche.
Felsiges Gelände, Methanseen, Kryovulkane
- das alles gibt es dort möglicherweise,
aber wir wissen es nicht genau.
Also haben wir darüber nachgedacht, wie wir
ein System schaffen können, das vielseitig
und in der Lage ist, verschiedene Geländetypen
zu durchqueren, das aber auch kompakt genug
ist, um mit einer Rakete zu starten."
Der Plan der NASA zielt darauf ab, kleine
wandelbare Roboter zu entwickeln, die den
Titan und seine Seen erforschen.
Die Erkundungs-Geräte sollen sich letztendlich
ganz von alleine zusammen- und wieder auseinanderbauen
können.
Ohne, dass sie dabei Anweisungen von der Erde
benötigen.
Zusammenarbeiten sollen die wandelbaren Roboter
mit einem Rover, der als Energiespeicher funktionieren
könnte.
Hier könnten sich die Transformer-Roboter
aufladen.
Zudem soll dieser Lander nach Plan der NASA
auch mit wissenschaftlichen Instrumenten ausgestattet
sein, um Proben auszuwerten.
Falls eine Region erkundet werden soll, zu
dem der Rover es aus eigener Kraft nicht schafft,
könnten sich zehn Roboter zusammenschließen
ihre Basis an diesen schwer erreichbaren Ort
fliegen.
Eine super coole Sache, denn so wäre der
Rover nicht an eine bestimmte Region gebunden.
Die NASA beschreibt den derzeitigen Prototypen
als “eine Vorrichtung, die aussieht wie
eine Drohne, die in einem länglichen Hamsterrad
eingeschlossen ist".
So kann sich der Shapeshifter rollend fortbewegen.
Doch dabei handelt es sich genau genommen
nicht nur um EINEN Roboter.
Zu solch einem Hamsterrad zusammengeschlossen
haben sich nämlich ZWEI Multicopter: Der
zylindrische Käfig besteht aus zwei Hälften.
Zwei Drohnen also, die gemeinsam Rollen können-
und doch ist jede für sich allein flugfähig.
Die Vorteile liegen auf der Hand: Hindernisse
können einfach umflogen werden und auch große
Distanzen sind fliegend schneller zurückzulegen.
Fahren beziehungsweise Rollen ist dagegen
energieeffizienter.
Der Plan der NASA sieht aber noch mehr Funktionen
vor.
Mehrere Roboter können auch als Schwarm die
Oberfläche eines Himmelskörpers erkunden.
Mit einem Propeller ausgestattet könnten
sie aber auch unzugängliche Höhlen erkunden.
Als Kette könnten sie dabei sogar die Kommunikation
mit der Oberfläche gewährleisten.
Als Kugel zusammengeschlossen könnten die
Roboter aber nicht nur Rollen, sondern auch
als eine Art Boot mysteriöse Seen aus Methan
erkunden.
Bisher existiert ein 3D-gedruckter Prototyp
namens “Shapeshifter”.
Dieses NASA-Projekt gehört zum sogenannten
Innovationsprogramms (NASA Innovative Advanced
Concepts) und somit ist nicht klar, wann dieses
Projekt für eine echte Mission ausgewählt
wird.
Fest steht aber schon: Die nächste Mission
zum Titan soll aber im Jahr 2026 starten.
Hier wird wohl der fliegende Rover Dragonfly
eingesetzt, um den spannenden Geheimnissen
des Saturnmondes auf die Schliche zu kommen.
Wie Roboter uns in Zukunft helfen, anklicken,
anschauen und Doktor Whatson abonnieren!
Bis dann bleibt dran